afternoon we'll have the Secretary
General make some remarks on the Black
Sea initiative he unfortunately will not
take questions and then I will brief
after them sir
good afternoon
we have some positive and significant
developments the confirmation by the
Russian Federation to continue its
participation in the Black Sea
Initiative for another 60 days
I welcome this decision the continuation
is good news for the worlds
outstanding issues remain
but representatives of Russia Ukraine
turkey and United Nations will keep
discussing them
I hope we will reach a comprehensive
agreement to improve expand and extend
the initiative as I proposed in a recent
letter to the presidents of the three
countries
and I want to convey my appreciation to
all those taking part in the
negotiations in a spirit of constructive
engagement
I once again expressed my gratitude to
president erdogan and the government of
turkey for their efforts working in
permanent coordination with United
Nations
the importance of the Black Sea
initiative and the parallel memorandum
of understanding between the U.N and the
Russian Federation is clear
these agreements matter for Global Food
security
Ukrainian and Russian products feed the
worlds
and that the Black Sea initiative more
than 10 million tons of food have been
exported
vital Food Supplies are reaching some of
the world's most vulnerable people and
places
including 30 000 tons of wheat that just
left Ukraine aboard the wfp chartership
to feed hungry people in Sudan
they matter because we are still in the
throes of a record-breaking cost of
living crisis
over the last year markets have
stabilized volatility has been reduced
and we have seen Global food prices fall
by 20 percent
and they matter because they
demonstrated even in the darkest hours
there is always a Beacon of Hope and an
opportunity to find solutions that
benefit everyone
looking ahead
we hope that exported food and
fertilizers including ammonia
from the Russian Federation in the
Ukraine will be able to reach Global
Supply chains safely and predictably as
foreseen in both the Black Sea
initiative and the memorandum of
understanding on Russian food and
fertilizer exports the implementation of
which the United Nations is fully
committed to support thank you
thank you very much thank you
welcome
foreign
okay
good afternoon see when the boss is here
we start almost on time
um all right I'll take your questions
after this I do have a few things uh for
you uh after this we will be
um joined by Mommy mizutori the special
representative of Secretary General for
disaster uh risk reduction uh she'll be
here to brief you on the high level
meetings on the midterm review of the
Sendai framework for disaster risk
reduction
um
you will have seen that yesterday uh
evening we announced that the Secretary
General no surprise will be going to the
G7 uh meetings which will be held in a
Hiroshima Japan
um he will take part in uh two working
session with Partners one on uh Saturday
entitled working together to address
multiple crises where he's expected to
call on G7 countries to deliver
Financial Justice for developing
countries who are facing an
international system that is unfair and
dysfunctional the Secretary General also
take Park in the common uh Endeavor for
resilient and sustainable planet where
his message to G7 countries will be to
create the conditions for dramatic
reduction of emissions in the present
decade both in developed and emerging
economies including the phasing out of
fossil fuels and ramping up of renewable
energy he will also refer to the need
for Effective solidarity with developing
countries by providing the much needed
Finance so they can also make the
transition and increase climate
resilience uh during his visit to
Hiroshima the Secretary General will
also meet with prime minister uh fumio
kishida of Japan who is the host of this
year's G7 as well as other leaders uh in
the um
uh who are attending it and we'll give
you updates on the bilaterals as they
happen uh over the um over the weekend
um also this morning the special Envoy
for Yemen Hans grunberg briefed the
security Council in person he said he's
encouraged by the positive and detailed
discussions he had with yemeni parties
in Regional interlocutors adding that
despite some challenges there is room
for cautious optimism and Mr grunberg
will be at the Stakeout to speak to you
uh probably in about 45 minutes to an
hour but we will keep you posted on that
uh turning to Syria uh after 100 days
after February's devastating earthquakes
which also hit turkey we continue to
respond to Urgent humanitarian needs in
both countries but I'll just focus on
Syria for today across the country we
and our partners have provided more than
2 million hot meals millions of people
have also received ready to eat food
rations and other forms of food and cash
distance we've worked to ensure access
to Safe Drinking Water and hygiene and
sanitation services including in
reception centers and sites hosting
internally displaced people millions of
people have received health services and
shelter support we have removed hundreds
of thousands of cubic meters of debris
rehabilitated classrooms health
facilities and other critical
infrastructure children separated from
their families and survivors of
gender-based violence have also received
protection and a support since the
earthquakes more than 2 200 trucks
carrying you and Aid have moved into
Northwest Syria from Southern turkey we
continue to send supplies through the
three available Crossing points on a
daily on an almost daily basis we also
have completed about a hundred
interagency cross-border missions
into the Northwest since February 14th
our three-month flash appeal for the
earthquake response in Syria was fully
uh funded and thanks to the generosity
of donors meanwhile many uh relief
activities will continue under the
annual humanitarian response plan which
is less than eight percent funded to
date and in Turkey a humanitarian needs
remain high with some 3 million people
forced to relocate more than half a
million more than half a million
buildings have sustained uh serious
damage we and our partners have
supported the government-led efforts
helping reach more than 4 million people
with humanitarian assistance including
1.4 million children this support
includes food shelter Health cash
assistance and Water Sanitation hygiene
Services the three months flash appeal
for turkey wrapped up today with more
than
353 million dollars received in the
months ahead we and our partners will
continue to back government efforts to
deliver
urgent assistance is needed turning to
Sudan we along with our humanitarian
Partners today called for 3 billion US
dollars to help millions of people in
the country and hundreds of thousands
fleeing to neighboring countries the
humanitarian response plan for Sudan has
been revised and requires 2.56 billion
dollars that's an increase of 800
million dollars from just a few months
ago to help 18 million people until the
end of this year making it the largest
appeal ever for Sudan the Sudan Regional
Refugee response plan seeks 470.4
million dollars to support refugees
returnees and host communities in the
Central African Republic Chad Egypt
Ethiopia and South Sudan on the ground
in Sudan we're working to ramp up
life-saving assistance for millions of
people in need wfp has reached more than
200 000 people to date with over 5500
of food distribution is also underway in
the states of Al Jazeera gadariv kasala
White Nile North Darfur and East Darfur
this includes nutrition support which is
also going on in Red Sea state wfp is
planning to expand operations in Blue
Nile central door for northern states
this week yesterday four trucks from
UNICEF moved supplies from soba to Al
Jazeera Crossing conflict lines with
health and nutrition supplies including
emergency health kits containing
Essential Health supplies a quick update
from the
um
Central African Republic and our
peacekeeping mission there in the vakaga
prefecture which borders uh Sudan the
security situation remains unstable and
there's a steady influx of people
arriving from Sudan not surprisingly the
mission continues to monitor the
situation engage with local authorities
and Community leaders to ensure the
protection of civilians the mission also
maintains a temporary presence in the
village of tiringulu also in the vakaga
prefecture to prevent violence following
attacks by armed groups earlier this
month against Central African forces
Defense Forces in the same prefecture
the mission is also working jointly with
undp to provide technical logistical
security assistance to advance electoral
mapping to facilitate local elections
and from Ethiopia humanitarian
colleagues tell us that recent floods
have caused significant displacement of
people and damage in the country south
and east the Somali region is the most
affected with more than 35
000 households displaced in more than 45
lives lost more than 23 000 livestock
has died nearly a hundred thousand
hectares of Farmland have been destroyed
due to the floods food shelter
agricultural nutrition health support
are the top of the list of humanitarian
needs the floods are also heightening
health risks in places where there's an
ongoing cholera outbreak
we in our humanitarian Partners along
with the government are providing
life-saving assistance but we need more
funding more cash
coordinated allocation of 40 million
dollars by the Ethiopian humanitarian
fund and the central emergency response
front is being prepared to address the
immediate needs of drought and flood
impacted people but to date only 22
percent of the four billion dollars
required for the humanitarian response
plan has been received
um and just a quick note for Mali where
wfp is calling for Urgent funding to
ramp up emergency food and nutrition
assistance to 3.8 million women men and
children in central Northern and South
Central Mali
wfp's expanded response will Target hard
to reach uh areas this year wfp plans to
provide emergency food and nutrition
assistance to 3.8 million people in uh
Mali the agency needs 110 million
dollars over the next six months for its
operations funding constraints has
already forced wfp to reduce food
rations by 50 percent in host
communities in April and May without
adequate funding they will be forced to
put in place even deeper cuts and come
next month
um
and uh just the fact that yesterday the
under Secretary General for peace
operations jean-pierrelecua wrapped up
his visit to unmik
um upon his arrival on May 11th in
Pristina Mr Lacroix participated in an
event to Mark Inter-Community trust
building efforts in Kosovo that featured
the launch of the barabar community
dialogue Center a joint multi-ethnic
initiative by two ngos and Pristina in
North mitrovica to Foster into communal
dialogue he also met with a number of
Civil Society organization and religious
leaders across Kosovo where unmake Works
alongside local Partners as part of
broader efforts to build social cohesion
and Inter-Community trust lines with its
mandate uh
and during his visit Mr Lacroix also met
with President
um Osmani sadru and prime minister Alban
korti among other leaders to discuss the
recent developments regarding the EU
facilitated dialogue as well as U.N
support to peace building uh to be build
peace and Trust among kosovo's
communities and he met with unmixed
staff and the UN Kosovo team and
international partners he then went on
to Belgrade where he held discussions
with prime minister uh Anna bronovich
first Deputy Prime Minister and foreign
minister Ibiza dachich to discuss the
nobilization process Regional stability
Economics work on trust building in his
meeting with the Deputy Prime Minister
and Minister of Defense Mr vuchevich Mr
Lacroix thanks Serbia for its
contribution to U.N peacekeeping
globally to date World mural
meteorological organization launched a
very important report that says that
global temperatures are set to reach new
records in the next five years wmo says
there is 66 percent chance that the
Global surface temperature will
temporarily exceed 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels for at least one
in the one in the next five years and in
98 likelihood that at least one of the
next five years will be the warmest on
records
today is the International Day against
homophobia transphobia and biphobia just
the flag that an equal World depends on
recognizing and respecting diverse
identities with that in mind the theme
this year is together always United in
diversity today is also World
telecommunications and Information
Society day which helps raise awareness
on the possibilities that the use of the
internet and other information
communication Technologies can bring to
societies and economies uh
sorry tomorrow our guest will be friend
equisa unicef's representative
in Afghanistan which would be a very
interesting briefing
Michelle
Christian following the sj's remark
um he mentioned outstanding issues can
you give us an indication of what some
of those outstanding issues
um are particularly and
um what was his sort of involvement over
the past few days in getting this over
the line with Russia um has he received
any communication from Russia the
secretary Journal I think has been as uh
involved in this initiative
um as I've seen him involved in any
initiative over his last uh six seven
years that he's been um he's been in
office uh he's been working the phones
he's had uh he's had meetings uh with
Russian officials he's been working I
mean speaking with Ukrainian officials
as well of course
um
along with keeping
very much abreast of the work that
Martin Griffis is doing the Rebecca
Greenspan is is doing
um
there was on the issues um you know
there was a quad meeting yesterday
though we expect to have another quad
meeting today
there are a lot of hurdles and I think
the Secretary General uh made that clear
in his remarks I think one of the
the reasons we've been able to have
success on this initiative is
our ability to
keep things discreet when they need to
be discreet and working them out uh and
being very public when we need to be uh
very public
so I will this I know it's not the
answer you'd like
um but our aim is to keep this going uh
for the clear reasons of 30 million tons
of of grain having been exported for uh
the the advances we've made on the
facilitation of Russian
fertilizer and grain as well
talks about outstanding issues is it
fair to say that he's referring to
outstanding issues with the Russian
export
there listen
let's not let's zoom out a little bit
let's remember that we have
um
we have representative of two countries
they're involved in a conflict
sitting across the table from each other
in Istanbul making this initiative work
along with the support of turkey
we are working uh to get over all the
hurdles on on Russian uh food and and
fertilizer so they're they're this is a
complex and complicated uh emotions run
run high
and things need to be smoothed out uh on
a daily basis and that's where our focus
is
sorry just final question so he's also
possibly indicating issues within the
JCC where you know
we've seen we've seen issues about the
JCC things need to be worked out uh I
mean these are representatives of
countries that are fighting each other
on a daily basis of course they're going
to be issues our aim is to smooth out
those issues
Edie
a couple of follow-up stuff
um
you said that there had been
um meetings of the four parties
yesterday and today
to iron out these outstanding issues uh
what kind of follow-up are
are you expecting I mean the follow-up
is obviously continuous meetings uh at
The JCC Rebecca Greenspan's continuous
efforts
um
you know to keep these two things going
is Around the Clock operation uh and we
are working uh we're working at that
level
and one's limit but but um is there any
timetable to try and get what reach what
the Secretary General called the
comprehensive agreement to improve
expand and extend the initiative
let's enjoy the day today
Valeria
then Desi and Maggie
thanks Steph another follow-up on this
so
are you getting closer to overcome these
issues or
you are on the same uh let's say path
that you were like before this renewal
is the Secretary General awful that
these two months would be enough for
you know at the risk of overusing the
sg's favorite quote from Jean Monet he
remains determined he's not optimistic
he's not pessimistic he remains
determined and Rebecca Greenspan and
Martin Griffiths have adhered to Jean
Monet's
vision of how to move forward there will
be issues there are issues where things
will continuously pop up for the reasons
that are outlined to to Michelle but
we're continuing our work
on with determination
deji then Margaret
so I gotta follow-up also on this uh
extension uh just a wording question
because I real I I noticed that this
initiative has been changed from Galaxy
Grand initiative to Black Sea initiative
what what does that imply no I mean
we're just the the the the wording in uh
uh in in the agreement uh remains uh
Remains the Same okay and your next
question oh yeah I got I got uh other
questions on the on the visit of
Secretary General to Japan
uh we know that it's a tradition for
Secretary General to visit a G7 Summit
and uh but for this year it seems this
uh G7 Summit is more or less they they
have a very obvious Target which is
China because we mean we we saw those
stories from different news outlets
about what they call China economic
cohesion
does the Secretary General feel if he
went to Japan this time for G7 that
makes people feel like he's taking the
side no I mean it's not a matter of
taking side the Secretary General is
going to the G7 with a very specific
message as speaking on on behalf of
those countries that have felt left out
and are left out of the International
Financial system that are not being
helped to gain or go over the the the
financial the the climate crisis
um that's what he's he's not going there
to endorse or not endorse whatever G7
he's not a member of the G7 he's I mean
you know for all the obvious reasons
he's there he will deliver a very direct
message and I think if you look at the
language of the announcement it is
pretty direct uh and I think you know
him he speaks his mind and he will he
will uh he will do so and that's why
he's going and I think that's why every
Secretary General you know has attended
G7 meetings it's very important for the
Group of Seven to hear
his voice on behalf of others we saw
that we saw the schedule and he's in the
schedule it says he will stress the
economic deep coupling is not an option
there uh given the situation now about
all this do you think everybody will
listen
don't ask me
as those as those around the others
around around the table of course I very
much hope that people listen to every
word that the Secretary General says uh
he's given a lot of thought to what he's
going to say and what he has said
uh Margaret then
Gregory then Alan and then we'll keep
going
is he doing a letter does he do the
letter to the G7 or the G20 usually
usually I think it's his dear it's a
drg20 letter not a dear G7
there's seven of them he could speak to
all of them directly it doesn't need to
I guess so yeah speaking of letters any
uh response from President Putin to the
sg's letter on the grain deal
let's enjoy today okay and then just on
the on these quad meetings just to be
very precise they are all four together
at the same day like Russia and Ukraine
are at the same table fine right so
let's see
at the JCC every day they are there in
person right there is a uh Ukrainian
representative there's a Russian
representative there's a representative
from turkey and of course uh the U.N on
the quad meeting some of them are in
persons uh some of them are on online
okay and then
as Mr Griffin said Miss Greenspan
participating uh I will check okay and
where are they at the moment do you know
uh Mr Griffiths is in Geneva
Miss Greenspan is most likely in Geneva
but I have a hard time keeping track of
the two of them okay and then just on
one other subject on Myanmar we just
heard from the special repertoire uh
does the Secretary General have any
reaction to this report about a billion
dollars worth of arms going to the
military in Myanmar and many of it being
used for what he says amount to crimes
against humanity uh
as you know the the very important work
that the special reporters do are
independent of of the Secretary General
including in their reporting I think we
have not been shy at expressing our deep
deep concern at the situation in uh in
Myanmar at the way the authorities uh in
power have behaved notably uh in the
violence against civilians in the
continued Detention of uh thousands of
people including uh political uh leaders
uh so I think our
our position is is clear but I don't
have a specific reaction to that uh
report
Gregory then Allen
uh thank you Stefan uh first question
please uh uh president erdogan said
it's also moving which moving from the
Ukrainian ports nikolaev and all via so
does it mean that the deal is expanding
uh for these Sports and the second one
please uh are there any concrete plans
uh how Secretary General team will work
on the remaining issues during this two
months
um uh will continue to work uh to work
on termination Ms Greenspan was
continues extremely actively
um
president erdogan said about the
was that's an issue
sorry some issue
yesterday does you remember
the question is uh did you manage to uh
verify
foreign
thank you
could I try
all right Alan why are you being let's
try again yeah
let's add the security Council the
relevant letter with the statement by
this person I mean the head of the Intel
or Ukrainian intelligence
option is simple why
running such a statement
this particular statement I mean
permission
billions I've been very clear I have no
way to verify the claims that have been
made but I can tell you that we stand
against all acts of Terror by whomever
they may be uh conducted wherever they
may be uh conducted
um
it is very important uh that anyone in
uh
statements and and rhetoric is focused
on appease and then not inflamming it
thank you Stephen on Palestine
there is the Flag Day in East Jerusalem
thousands of the Israeli far right
expected to March through the old city
Muslim quarter in the past this has led
to repeated attacks
is there any message we very much hope
that there will be
uh Stefano then Toshi
it's about the initiative of Africa
certain countries and um president
the Secretary General has and he
couldn't see
because he was saying that that the two
the the two country conflict they still
think they want to win and everything
was it for him a surprise that actually
uh this African initiative and that
that's can you give us any more
particular any more details about what
the president of South Africa say to
good terrors
the the president president ramaphosa
spoke to the Secretary General uh
briefed him on the on on his plan uh
it's not a surprise that uh countries of
good faith are doing whatever they can
to try to bring an end uh to this
conflict everyone has a part to play
right
um and Secretary General is playing his
part uh and I think if you look again if
you look at what has been achieved uh at
The JCC it's it's very important and
it's very critical all these things can
be built built upon
so it is
we all want to see an end to this
conflict and enter this war in line with
the charter in line with General
Assembly resolutions and in line with
International
uh law and we very much we hope that
this initiative succeeds but because the
president of South Africa actually
called the Secretary General on the same
day actually the day before he announced
that was it this because he needed some
advices from him what what I mean I
think it's it's only uh I I think we
very very much appreciated the that
president ramaphosa took the time uh to
call the Secretary General it was very
uh courteous and I think it's it's not
surprising that uh someone who's
launching a peace initiative uh called
the Secretary General of the United
Nations at a time like this to inform
him of what he or she is doing okay
thank you then just an Amanda think just
coming here that we're outside the the
building
um a delegation of
um a women immigrant women that work as
home care workers and they had a
petition for the United Nations and now
the guard of course they couldn't take
it and they give it to
to me and the day is that petition about
the United Nations to declare 24 hours
workday is a crime against humanity
basically in New York City there are
apparently thousands of women there are
immigrants and they work in 24 hours
taking care of people in need they said
that they already went to City Hall they
did a lot but just that just uh can I
give it to you then what is the question
I don't know my question I I don't I
mean this is Stefano this is a press
briefing I will tell you that uh the the
issue is an extremely important one and
we often see marginalized communities
especially immigrant communities being
taken advantage of in every country all
over the world uh I think for all those
who travel we've all we've all seen it
it is important that member states
uphold the the rule of law uphold
International labor standards
Toshi and then we'll go to the screen
then I'll come back thank you Stefan uh
regarding the secretary General's visit
to Japan I have a quick quick question
on his schedule he's leaving uh today
and which means uh is there no he's
leaving tomorrow you know and I think we
it's our we put out the announcement
yesterday which said he was leaving
tomorrow because the original plan they
put out would would have been to put out
the announcement today because he's
leaving tomorrow so it's our band
so thank you for paying attention
uh uh Abdul Hamid and Pam please
okay uh Pam Folk
Abdul Hamid one of you
okay uh Edie why don't you go ahead
um
this is a non-grain deal question
excellent or Ukraine uh does the
Secretary General have
any reaction to the announcement by
science un scientists today
that the world
will likely uh warm to Beyond 1.5
degrees Centigrade by 2027.
I think the message is to policy makers
to the private sector listen to the
signs listen to the facts and act now